we lost follow us
the lost friends you lost family today
we have a chance to take it all back
we will whatever it takes whatever it
takes
whatever it takes how's it going
everybody it's Warren and in kind of a
big surprise we got a new Marvel Studios
of vengers in game TV spot this morning
Marvel Studios and the Russo brothers
are definitely doing a really good job
by keeping us in the dark when it comes
to Avengers in game this new TV spot
doesn't really reveal anything
in fact besides the flashbacks on the
heroes that we lost all the footage for
endgame is the same in this trailer it's
the same footage we saw in the second
official trailer however some of what
Captain America is saying is new he says
we lost all of us we lost friends we
lost family today we have a chance to
take it all back
we will whatever it takes it's
interesting that he says today we have a
chance to take it all back so it seems
like he's saying this before they go on
their mission probably before they go
inside of the quantum room so this is
most likely one of Captain America's pep
talks to the Avengers before they go
into battle one thing to note is that
when they show the Avengers walking in
the Avengers compound and they just show
their silhouettes right before they show
a close-up of them in the white suits
nebula is not in the scene we see
Captain America Tony Stark Black Widow
rocket ant-man war machine and Hawkeye
but we don't see nebula although she is
in the next scene wearing a white suit
just like all of the other Avengers so
unless this is a different scene which I
don't think it is there is clearly some
tampering going on with these trailers I
do however think that the final scene in
this TV spot with all of the Avengers
walking in white including nebula is
real and that the scene of them walking
from the first trailer was actually
meant to throw us off and not give
anything away and that's it for the new
Avengers in game TV spot again only 30
seconds because it's a TV spot and
nothing really new here but we're almost
a month away from the movie coming out
it's getting really exciting and we'll
probably get a couple more TV spots just
like this before the movie comes out so
let me know what you think about this
new TV spot and let me know what you're
most excited to see in Avengers endgame
let me know in the comments down below
and a quick reminder about my giveaway
I'm giving away five imax tickets so you
and some friends can go see Avengers
in-game if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorites
per hero or villain as always thank you
all so much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]